you there watching this video say this
sentence round and round the rugged Rock
the ragged rascal ran
not seriously say it because how you say
that sentence determines quite a bit
about the way you talk Jonathan Ross for
those who don't know him is a talk show
host and TV presenter in the UK he's
known for many things including a speech
defect he can't make her breath sound
properly according to the general public
he says what instead this is a running
joke the extent that his Twitter handle
is Wasi there are speech defects got a
long history Elmer Fudd has it he was
hunting rabbits if you want to make a
character seem weak or ineffectual it's
a good defect to give them love true
love has the waist from The Princess
Bride said but before you laugh at that
here's a test for you say that sentence
again and recover my mouth this time so
you don't get any clues pay attention to
what you're doing with your mouth when
you make the rcent here we go round and
round the rugged Rock the ragged rascal
ran
make that our sound hold it there are
two ways of doing this number one it's
like a run with your tongue against the
roof of your mouth
if you can go Allah Allah utter and they
feel very similar you say it this way
the other way of doing it it's like a V
hmm with your top teeth near your bottom
lip if a ver / / / seem very similar to
you then you say it this way if you say
it the second way then congratulations
you've got the same so-called speech
defect as Jonathan Ross and the same
speech defect as me in the same as a
heck of a lot of younger people there
are areas of Britain now where the so
called defective way is now the majority
particularly among folks younger than 30
like invasion of the Body Snatchers the
changes happened subtly quickly and
hardly anyone has noticed because to the
untrained ear and even to many trained
ears it sounds exactly the same I
wondered as a kid why I couldn't roll my
arse it's because the sound is nothing
like the Brooke sound I made and if
you've always wondered why some speakers
of some languages confuse utter and look
like Japanese and Polynesian languages
well it's because they don't distinguish
between the two they're the same gesture
now that only makes sense if your breath
sound really is like your look the only
way you can tell in my speech at least
is that I / aspirate pro and Brussels
right bring brother there's a of
escaping air in brother as my mouth
switches from a bilabial stop but but
but to this sound or a labia dental
approximate labia dental because it uses
lips and teeth and approximate because
they're near each other but not touching
it's not a one what is a labial velar
approximate with the lips close together
and the tongue raised the back of the
throat this is the labial dental
approximate phonetic symbol and when
transcribing politicians are using it
more and more and more so if you ask me
it stopped being a speech defect and
it's just an alternative way of making a
sound now Jonathan Ross was ahead of his
time so which one do you use
you